Saavik assume edifice in Yokohama FAC
surface panel the toy unity could field
only capital of a family in your
organization telecommute have a young
Rama Lama Don America secretary-general
you can say I am very focused and I am
focused because much is at stake in the
future of our currency or economy and we
have to take it all this very seriously
Allah Papa has some a new survivors were
the sons you are the Papa has shown a
pool demote in seven days when it was
rules
we're into the Italian language now 25
pages each each language version my main
responsibility is to prepare in this
case the treaty which will be signed on
the 2nd of March today we are preparing
the text should fit perfectly this is a
signature ceremony you want it to be as
easy as possible and to run as smoothly
as possible so that's the simple reason
why we're doing this
so yesterday both UPN hey refer to the
possibility that the arms would table
the new resolution in my New York I
would say that we integrate it in his
speaking points for the introduction on
External Relations Syria Arab Spring
there's of course one subject which in
it which is still under discussion so we
have to wait for the discussions of of
today because there may be still a
couple of problems around
we have high-ranking visitors with the
President of the European Council is the
president of Syrians things are not over
Serbia didn't reach candidate status we
try to fix the problem
probably this evening if it is not
possible we have to discuss it at the
European Council Thursday high and to
show that the sequence here to today the
secret of the deal way on under a minute
the classic there is a positive
confirmation of the criteria being met
but the decision is not being taken
I have a meeting with the director
general of the WTO Pascal language on
ellipse Allah they do your knowledge
decision that's not real he sees I can
operate a perusal
Saleucami this admit leader Pocket
Edition
blow us all fits Chris Berg answer is
recession emile zola Priscilla camera
for an image popped to second ship the
talent and the seniority apparently
Cheverus also have Edith under boom
longer
and top line in Mary's the rapture
it when the speech value from the
visitor will be take another example
unlike a douchebag and press conferences
for brides and the Kabir the water
defendant be possible by the mom and
Akbar hibachi [ __ ] in now the yellow met
maneuver Papa shelf so and then I try to
reorganize around the three key keywords
crisis trust and and conflict
enlargement will be on the agenda as
well as further accession to the
Schengen area
Monona von Sydow one of those movie so
people to share elbows and I said Sicily
the montage that a fabulous shape the
tide the government safety in grant AB
cafe all symmetric elk we don't call a
beside the Sun lap a Coppola DPA in for
tourism it's any sort of video streaming
plan plan for the signing ceremony of
the fiscal compact summits are the big
thing for all the journalists see and
that's and therefore it's also the big
thing for us the spokespeople we will
try to make available quickly was what's
agreed on Syria here to do the surface
the day a minute may oversee the
disciple Aquila and Amina's personnel
the president's a collaborator had an
SSA who till Donna Daniel ended what is
that what if Gaza first
it's Tuesday Pietra fari mid-foot to her
at the curve that's it no problem and
okay we have to show the ship please you
know what you are a provision and we're
here today on the eve of a European
Council practically I'm responsible for
making sure that tomorrow when the heads
of state and government become for
European Council they have all they need
to do their work properly it's quite a
big job it's like running a small
village making sure that everything is
there so that the leaders can take the
right decisions
don't want YEC to show a clip rare and
severe against you holy flab a bit of
last two at home plus for any additional
DNA
this meeting this morning is with
President Barroso and President Van
Rompuy we are planning the day basically
good morning let's go to the agenda of
the European Council of this palolem
nailed up you 370 European Council is
not much different in terms of concept
of any summit that could be held
anywhere in the world the difference
between all of those and us is that we
do honor almost monthly basis
fiscal consolidation remains unavoidable
to keep our social model sustained it is
a very busy day will end after midnight
the president we have good news now
concerning the candidate status the
China that they have broken our
agreement and signed this meeting
protocol and we hope that this will no
paper way to decision without discussion
heart issue must get to the persons all
right handle death
even more compact we have a number of
participants in this room as you can see
we have a local police for the outside
perimeter we have the Federal Police for
export purposes and we do have the
Belgian special forces in the house
also for a protected mission for a
country on a higher threat level but
also for interior protection we have
people moves and people who stand by
close to the main meeting room all these
people together coordinate in case of
major events
very big day for you we've got any
interesting no relays to take I'll
welcome you all either Opie's got the
most important thing about interpreting
is not the words it's not the language
itself it's the the message it's the
spirit of what's being put across cause
if I don't assume it we have instantly
to understand what people are trying to
say and to convey that message in the
same tone in the same spirit
it's excellent day it's a second mandate
let's get started
hola
Eva owner if not consult in 30 seconds
you are there I am very honored that you
have all decided to ask me to continue
as president of the European Council for
a second mandate today we have 1800
equality journalists in the press center
there is a lot of information flowing in
this area from delegations from
institutions etc more or less informally
and therefore we have to try to always
keep things into context try to give
them indications on what's being
discussed on timing
best conference in LA and open an
occupation up and what enough to blast
women fact of the most high color
printer Muhammad button down at last
news to be no vehicle for the for the
best confidential
during this council we have a wide range
of issues to discuss continuing this
work for Europe in some designs of times
is a privilege and
deep in the fifties protocols possessed
any manner of crap mr. Seagal a volcanic
Asuka
I hear her coming here often Houghton
typical Indian family me I have
she could've listed it as the sixth me
and his hidden Disney job
this Gator hunters Milad facility to bid
on offers this has the pension Biscayne
and talked to feel good recently dog
chow yun-fat on film la vida chef that I
don't initiate the time he was another
no protocol a but was the back evaluate
sample SOPs a check for a top our
cameras are you mean it is fine no
passing
more than the normal teenage report put
it all the time only pretty facility
uncle initial data Honda LaSalle who la
Vida mala PI server bodies imagine a
people other special dogs a couple that
water gosh suppose having some lap or a
very blockade over the other ferret
offshore one woody well everyone signed
you can see about four five minutes to
go around the round the room so short
and sweet it's a done deal
what you see here is dedicated teams of
translators and assistant servicing
exclusively the summit meeting everyone
wants to get as fast as possible
diversions in their own languages which
allows them to give a final check to the
conclusions
we should start in about five minutes
I'm just going to place you on hold
until we start hello everybody
Tonkin photography madness acres of Ian
debriefing publishes the delegation
renewal generally 20 bucks curve IV
demolishes no delegation on the question
of XP kiss kiss passionately Kosovo Piaf
exit rate a new initiative a desequerah
basically our responsibility a
solidarity yes a decision official
Lokhande to laaser be pull your rope
Ian's back Larry - yeah kalkaluru
honestly truly problem photocopies lady
shows vision
satisfy oppress and a waitress at us
you